we weren't able to talk about it then
but now we can talk about poor old Thor
yeah in that film he's sort of he did
eat his feelings he definitely ate his
way through his emotions some pictures
but that you didn't do that oh no that
was my full Raging Bull Oscar attempt I
mean it so this is a fat suit lose it
now as much remarkable thing it's a yeah
no good it's a prosthetic like takes
kind of thing which literally I would
slip into they weighed about 60 70
pounds was that 30 40 kilograms with his
zipper up the back and they're taking
photos of my body and then every little
screw of the hair or freckle or whatever
the hell that was on that thing it was
that's my body and in like six months
time like Thor was depressed but we was
it depressing walk for you walk here
mind like that I was so much fun treat
you differently as I was heading down
yeah every time I step toward the
catering truck they were like no no no
no we were we were doing an interview
yesterday and the journal it for Good
Omens and the journalist said ask me we
were in the fat suit for it
this doesn't zipper do she she did him
afraid she didn't really recover from
that moment did you get the pregnant
lady thing where people was want to
touch your stomach got a lot of cuddles
I've had four if she's had three kids
and often you know they're pregnant like
the belly rub in the supermarket and
Robert Downey got me a fair share
everyone were starting to coddle me
after like Santa Claus you know yeah you
sort of Avengers on my lap from time to
time
[Music]